- That's also why it's so
wonderful that you know,
sites like Locals
are springing up
and are gonna provide
an alternative.
Nature abhors a vacuum,
markets abhor a vacuum.
I love if these
Twitter guys are gonna,
and YouTube are gonna play
the game the way they want to.
There's about 47% of Americans
who wanna hear dissident voices
and who will be
really tuning in.
(light electronic music)
- Joining me today is the
former CEO of overstock.com.
A man dubbed the renaissance
man of e-commerce
by Fortune magazine,
a cryptocurrency
enthusiast and more.
Patrick Byrne, welcome
to the Rubin Report.
- It is such an honor to
be on your show David,
it really is.
- Patrick.
- I've been watching
you for four years
and just become such an admirer.
I feel I've made the big time.
- This is it man.
I mean look, I went
through your bio today
and I said okay, there's
some impressive stuff here,
but this is it, this is it.
- Yes, no it reads better,
as I say in theater,
it all reads better
than it played, my bio.
But no this is it.
Making it here is, I
think that you have become
such a intellectual
center of gravity
for the freedom movement
that I really am excited
to be on the show.
- Thanks, thanks, well
we, I appreciate that
and we happened to
bump into each other
just a couple weeks ago,
it was the second time.
You didn't even
remember the first time
because it was backstage at
some Yal event or something,
but we saw each other, we
chatted for a little bit
and this is long overdue,
but you are making a
Rubin Report first here
because just as I sat
down a moment ago,
I opened up my
Twitter to say well,
what's Patrick up to just so
I can ask him something timely
off the bat and boy oh boy,
you are doing something timely.
You have been banned
from Twitter literally
in the last like 10 minutes.
I saw your profile, I
saw you following me,
I saw the tweets.
I refreshed just to see if
you had put anything new up.
You're gone, you're
gone, so congratulations?
- All the best people are
today, don't you think?
- What did you do,
what did you do?
- Well, I've been
sort of teasing Jack.
There's a tweet, someone
should go back a few days ago
and find I put up
I something like,
Jack is it verboten to list
a 19th century philosopher,
a quote from a 19th
century philosopher?
I've been doing
things like that.
I don't think I've been
violating any terms of services,
but just kind of
ridiculing them.
John Stuart Mill wrote
this beautiful statement
about free speech
and it was basically,
he who knows only half of,
he only knows his own
side of an argument
only knows half of the argument
and it's not enough to
have teachers tell you
what the other side is
and then give you their,
how they would answer it.
That you have to be able to
read the original material,
so there has to be free speech.
That's the only way we can
have a second discourse
and advance to society
so I put that up.
I'd like to think that
that's probably the,
be kind of funny
if posting 19th
century philosophy
is violating the
terms and conditions.
- If John Stuart Mill can
get you kicked off Twitter,
I'm pretty sure I would
be off of Twitter.
So I have a feeling it might
have been something else,
but in any event,
you're off the Twitter,
life goes on.
Real quick, I wanna focus
really for this time
on the censorship stuff,
on what you think some
of the solutions are,
on tech all of that, but for
the people that just have
no idea who you are,
you actually have a
pretty fascinating bio
and you've done some
really cool stuff.
Can you give me
like a minute or two
just like Patrick Byrne 101
and then we'll dive
into everything that's
happening right now.
- Patrick Byrne 101
is, I had a dual career
in business and academia.
Part of that's 'cause
was I got out of college,
I had cancer three times
and I spent a lot of my 20s
in the hospital and for want
of something better to do
and convalescing, I did
a PhD in philosophy.
I was something called
a martial fellow
and did that at Cambridge,
finished the PhD at Stanford,
but meanwhile I was also doing
all kinds of other things
on the side and those other
things just sort of built
until by the time I
was in my late 20s,
they were taking, they
were business ventures,
startups and
investments and such
and they kind of took over my
life for about 20, 25 years.
I'm happily, I left a year ago
'cause I knew that
I was gonna be
that I had been involved
in a lot of stuff
that was gonna be
seeing the light of day
and running a publicly
traded company as CEO,
I thought it would probably,
I didn't know how it
was gonna come out,
but I knew it was gonna come out
and I thought it would
probably destroy the company
if I stayed, so I
punched out a year ago
and then started going public
with some of the things I know.
- Right and some of those things
that you have been
tweeting about are kind
of election related stuff that
to be quite frank with you,
if I was to bring up right now,
my channel could be
deleted like that.
That's just the sad truth of it,
but that's probably the
Segway that'll get us
to all the censorship stuff.
As a guy that you know,
you're an innovator,
you brought overstock to IPO,
you're a crypto guy, you're
involved in intelligence
and all of these things.
What do you make of
this very bizarre moment
that we're in, in terms
of the information war,
not even the specific
political you know,
Trump's got the
10 days left war.
- Yeah, well it's all part,
it's the fourth stage of a,
it's the fourth stage of a psyop
and the first stage
was the COVID,
the second stage was Antifa,
the demoralization,
disorientation,
then the election,
whatever happened there
we won't comment on it, but the
last stage is normalization.
So they have to
control the media
and normalize everyone's
belief in this election
and if you doubt it,
everyone's gonna treat
you like you're crazy
to doubt this election.
So this is really the
fourth and final stage
of a psyop where
I think they take
over the United States frankly.
So that's why this is
so crucial for them.
That's also why it's so
wonderful that you know,
sites like Locals
are springing up
and are gonna provide
an alternative.
Nature abhors a vacuum,
markets abhor a vacuum.
I love if these
Twitter guys are gonna,
and YouTube are gonna play
the game the way they want to.
There's about 47% of Americans
who wanna hear dissident voices
and who will be
really tuning in.
- So what are you
as someone that,
I think you're
pretty much like me.
You're either an old school
liberal or a libertarian,
somewhere in that spot.
What do you make of
what the government
either should have
done or could have done
or would have done
in all of the time
that it had to break
these companies up
or regulate them
or the rest of it?
I never felt there
was a good answer.
You know me, I like competition,
that's why I started Locals,
but do you think
Trump dropped the ball
in terms of there was a time
where maybe some of this
could have been dealt with.
- Yes, but I think
that they have,
the goons have gone to steps
that I doubt even
Trump anticipated
that they were gonna do things
like shut off Twitter
for 70,000 people.
(coughing)
Turn off sites.
Pardon me, I know I've
COVID as I told you,
but I'm surviving.
- You've had it
for a couple days,
you're alive, you're smiling.
- I'm alive, I think
I'm on day four.
It feels like a mild flu so far.
I'd say, what they
have done is so extreme
that it's really left a bad
taste in the mouth of anyone
but the most crazy Marxist
lefties can't you know,
they can't imagine in America.
Somebody's taking care of
me so that actually voted
for Biden and even she has
told me how horrified she is
about what's going on.
It's clearly they are
showing their hand
and showing America
what the America is
that you have to look
forward to in about a week
if this all goes
through as planned.
- Okay, so if Trump
couldn't have foreseen
some of this stuff, do you
think he just dropped the ball.
Like what would you have
done on the regulation stuff
knowing that these companies
were getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and yet
having the competition beliefs
and the limited
government beliefs.
- Well first of all, the
emergency broadcast system
should probably have been
extended to social media
and not just be in legacy media.
The rules of that, if the
government needs to communicate,
they need to communicate.
What if there's a nuclear
blast or something,
or a threat.
In addition, I think that
what they really have
to do is get rid of
this section 230.
You know, the whole principle
upon which it was all based,
and I remember 21 years ago
when they made the argument,
they said you can't, Yahoo
says you can't sue us
for stuff that appears
on the message board.
We're just like a
tree in the town park
and people go and nail
whatever they want on the tree.
We're value free, and on
that basis they got treated
not like a publisher who
could be sued for libel,
but they got treated like
just a neutral platform.
Well, our concept of a
publisher has to really expand.
You become a publisher
by using algorithms
that suppress certain
voices and elevate others,
that makes you a publisher.
Maybe you're not the
guy doing the typing,
but you have effectively
become a publisher.
So those exemptions they
have from the laws on libel
that govern say, newspapers
should not be there.
They shouldn't be there
and there should be guys
like Nick Sandman suing all
these social media companies
if they allow and
promote messages
that such as such as a racist
or such-and-such is
a fascist and such,
then you should be able
to sue just like you can
if the Washington Post
says it or CNN says it,
and of course we all
know that CNN coughed up
some couple hundred million
dollars or something
so they say to Nick.
So they ought to do that, that
same liability should attach
to Twitter, YouTube,
everybody else in the game.
- Yeah so do you see the,
what happened with
the servers to Parler.
So moving away from
Twitter for a second
and just the suppression
of whether they're
de-boosting you
or shadow banning you
or whether YouTube is
suppressing videos.
To actually in effect blow
up the servers of Parler,
you know, they removed this,
they didn't physically
blow them up, but you know,
they said you can't use
our servers anymore.
That's what Amazon said.
Do you view that as just
like a massive escalation
or is it just like
the obvious next step?
- No I do think it's
a massive escalation
that should get them sued.
You know, that should
really get them sued
for some great big
check because yeah,
you can't take your, you know,
what if AT&T, go
back to the 70s.
Suppose AT&T had
started saying oh,
when you talk on your
telephone long distance,
if you are promoting a democrat,
we're gonna turn you off.
Only republicans will
we let you talk about
on our AT&Tphone lines.
Well, I don't know, I'd say
that it would have
been ridiculous,
it would have been ridiculous.
Doesn't matter it's
a private company,
and so I think it's insidious.
I think it's extraordinary,
but it tells you the
kind of country we are
about to become in the
absence of intervention
of one kind or another.
You know, you've got
Nancy Pelosi saying
that they're gonna round up
children of Trump supporters
and think crazy stuff like that.
You know, if they
don't take a vaccine,
they're gonna take
your kids from you.
We're really turning
into a fascist state,
and I'm sure you as an
educated man David understand
that fascism is a
phenomenon of the left.
You were that whole history.
- Yeah, well this seems
to be the confusion
because everyone
seems to apply it
to the right and to Nazism.
But share with me please,
for my less educated viewers.
- Well 110 years ago there
was a hardcore socialist
in Italy, he ran the
socialist paper, Avanti.
He was considered so hardcore
he was almost distasteful
to some of the others.
He was a certain type of
socialist called a syndicalist
and you know, after Marx,
there's different
strands of socialism
and some strands are the
Leninist Stalin strand,
but there was another strand
that was like Proudhon
and George Sorel who believed
in worker participation
and worker democracies
blah, blah, blah
and they ended up
evolving this theory
of how to organize
society syndicalism
which is basically
everyone belongs to a union
of different kinds and
then the unions all meet
in the halls, the great
hall of the government
and with a firm hand
of the government
controlling and pushing,
they reach their deals
and then you as a minion
just live within the deal
that you're guild makes.
That's socialism.
The guy fought in World War
One, unlike most socialists
and he came back after World
War One and he had a twist,
he had a new frosting
which was that,
yes it is we socialists who
understand the world correctly,
but only we who have
been bloodied in battle
really have a place speaking
for the future of the nation,
and this guy's name was
as you probably guessed,
Benito Mussolini.
Benito Mussolini was
a hardcore socialist
and even when he
added nationalism,
he didn't change his view
of how you organize society.
So you really wanna think
of there being two
kinds of socialists.
There's the international
socialists like the Trotsky's
and then there's the national
socialists like the Mussolini
and then later his pal Adolf,
but they're phenomenons
of the left.
They're not free market
guys or anything like that.
Even yeah, that was all we
created after World War II
that we were taught to
think them as right wing.
They grew out of the left.
- Are you shocked that more
people don't know that?
I mean I remember when
I was on the young Turks
when I was a lefty like
five years ago or no,
it was more than that
now, seven years ago
or something like that.
It feels like ten lifetimes ago.
I remember saying something
like that on air once
about well, wait a minute,
weren't these guys
really on the left
if you really know
what leftism is
and everyone kind
of screaming at me,
but is everything
that we're seeing now
just a failure of
our education system
that nobody knows anything.
We don't, not only do
we not know history,
we're actively erasing history.
- It is indeed.
I don't know if you're aware
of my friendship
with Milton Friedman?
Do you know that story?
- No, I don't, but
I'd love to know it
because of course I have nothing
but admiration for
Milton Friedman.
- Milton thought that the
way you saved the nation was
with school choice
and he used to say
that our current
government school system
or our socialist school system
is gonna teach socialist values
and a free market system
would teach freedom.
He saw that's how we saved
the country in the long term.
Just before he died, about
a month before he died,
he called me and his
foundation was supposed
to dissolve at his
death and probably,
well not probably, the
single greatest honor
of my life was he called
me and said (mumbles).
I wanna change your will
and you're gonna carry on
in my name for 10 years
as the head of the
Friedman Foundation,
which I did and
then stepped down.
He said carry on for 10
years and you step down
and change the name
to something else
and so I did that for 10 years.
I think it's the way,
I think that so many of
the problems we face.
These government schools,
he wouldn't call
them public schools,
government schools
have really become
little indoctrination camps.
It's shocking to me how
this the nonsense history,
just fake history that
students get taught.
I've you know, working
as a CEO at a company
I of course interacted
with all kinds of you know,
age ranges and it's
just amazing how people
in their 20s are
so indoctrinated
and they don't know bubkus.
They don't know
bubkus about history.
I've got some very
close friends who are
I would call say, politely,
I call them kind of
militant black Muslims,
but we're good friends
and we spent a lot of
time debating stuff,
but I'm kind of surprised,
at least they know,
they know a lot,
but I'm generally surprised
when I deal even
with black activists
how little actual
history of slavery,
of black America do they know.
They've memorized a bunch of
ideological talking points
and spew it and they can't,
they don't think critically
about anything they've memorized
as a general rule which is why,
you know I think
what's really going on.
I'm old I'm a lot
older than you Rubin.
- I don't think you're
that much older than me.
- I got a lot of miles on me.
As Indiana Jones says,
it's not the years,
it's the miles.
I used to wonder, in the 1980s,
I lived in an
academic environment
where people were
arguing for socialism
and they were still
of the mentality
socialism because
science and economics.
Well by the end of the
1980s as that all collapsed,
they were kind of
silent for the 90s,
then they became socialism
because of ethics
and so there were all these
ethics programs set up
at universities and
from what I saw of them,
they basically,
their basic point was
if you're gonna be ethical,
you got to be a socialist
and then by about 2010
it became socialism
because you're racist,
then by about 2015 it became
socialism because shut up
and then more than
the last couple years
have become socialism
because black lives matter.
It's all intellectual goo.
And I wondered where
they were gonna go
when they ran out of, I
mean I was in academia
when I saw socialism collapse
as a worldwide movement
and I thought these, you know,
there's always the
control freaks among us.
They're gonna come back
someday with some new way
to pitch it and I've
seen in 20 years,
like I say there's three
or four different stages.
So this to me is just you know,
they can't even have
the arguments anymore.
They cannot even
conduct themselves
in a normal reasoned discourse
that you used to
take for granted
anyone at a college could do,
and since they can't
do that anymore,
they don't really wanna
have the arguments.
They don't wanna
have any debate.
They just wanna say
socialism because power.
- Have you been
able to figure out
how many sort of,
how many of them
actually believe it
versus how many of them
just go along with it?
So it's like I
don't think probably
that Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer
in their heart of hearts
are true socialists.
They might be bigger
government people than we are,
but I don't think they're
really socialist in that sense.
I sense AOC is probably
really a socialist,
Ilhan Omar is probably
but what do you make of
the way that they've just
sort of completely been
able to eat you know,
eat the last remaining liberals,
whatever you wanna call
them at this point?
- Well I think of you and
myself as the liberals.
- Yeah, yeah, I know
I'm trying, I'm trying.
- It's time we reclaim our word.
There are other words
that have been pejoratives
and then the people claim them.
It's time we do that.
Liberalism is what we are.
They stole our word
about 90 years ago
when it could no longer,
up until about 90 years ago,
you could sell socialism
in America as socialism.
After about 1930 because
we were becoming enemies
with the USSR, you couldn't
call yourself a socialist,
so they started calling
themselves liberals,
but they stole our word,
it's time we claim it back.
I'm sorry, so what do I think?
So I think that they,
well I don't know if
Nancy Pelosi really.
She understands power
and she wants more power
and more money and that's
all she understands,
and that's of course
gonna lead her down
to endorse increasingly
lefty projects.
There's a book, god I
haven't read it in 20 years.
Something like the
structure of revolutions.
It was about how,
about revolutions tend
to have a certain pattern
and one of the patterns is
they tend to keep lurching
toward the most extreme
members of the revolution.
The Jacobins defeat the,
whatever the guys were called,
the Third Estate or I forgot
what they were called.
The Bolsheviks defeat
the Mensheviks.
The US was the exception,
our revolution,
but when something
like this gets going,
there's this internal
dynamic where everybody
on the side of the revolution
or their revolution has
kind of an incentive
to be more extreme
than the other
and that's why the
thing just spills
and gets more more aggressive.
- Are you shocked
then that our system,
I mean I think a lot of people
are watching this going okay,
I kind of get it and
I kind of feel it,
but maybe this guy's a
little bit over the top,
but are you shocked
that our system
that so many conservatives
really believe in,
libertarians believe in the
ideas of the constitution
and the bill of rights
and freedom and federalism
and all of these things
that they were supposed
to have systems
that could stand
up to this and it,
we're watching the
systems just collapse.
I'm actually, right when I saw
you got banned from Twitter,
the next thing that I saw
was that the democrats are
now trying to push a thing
to ban the electoral college?
Like already, already.
- You know what is sad is
when you actually talk,
when I talk to my
activist friends
and if you even ask them,
gee well what is the argument
for the electoral college
or what is the argument
for free speech or,
they have no idea,
they have no idea.
They're like a little
kid going into a garden,
seeing stuff oh, I'm gonna
pull that up and look at it.
You know, they have no idea
how anything actually works
and so they wanna junk
everything and throw it out
and they have no idea
why the electoral
college was a good idea.
So I think that they're,
the thing to know about them
is when you actually engage
in discussion, they can't even
have intelligent discussions
as far as I can tell about
the background of these rules,
the background of
property rights,
the background of free speech.
What is it that made one
little clump on earth
suddenly explode 500, 600
years ago and do so well?
That's because we figured out
certain philosophical
principles.
Religious freedom and
in general freedom
for your own conscience,
all kinds of things worked
and they're just
ready to junk them
and they can't even tell you,
they don't know anything.
I'm so disappointed actually.
When I talk to activists,
it's shocking to me.
Even on the subject of
black America and slavery,
they know nothing about
the history of slavery.
They just have some
talking points.
No, they don't do serious work.
- It's so interesting
because I just covered this.
I'm sure you saw,
this Biden speech
where he's talking about
COVID relief and he says well,
we're gonna help
black and Hispanic
and Pacific Islander and
blah, blah, blah first,
and it's like, that's actually
against the constitution.
That's against the,
forget that MLK guy,
it's against the constitution
that we don't curry favor
based on the color of your skin
and yet it's so brazenly
being pushed on us
by the guy they told
us was the moderate.
- Right, and if you
go along with it,
if you have a society like that,
then you need a
government agency
that's the department of
who's been naughty and nice.
Who's the one who gets
the bad treatment,
who's the one who gets
the good treatment.
Once you have a
government agency
of who's been naughty and
nice or whatever they call it,
making decisions like
that, then you have this,
you know that's just,
it's a terrible solution.
Anyone, any child can will
know what's gonna happen
over a decade if
that, in a government
where the government is trying
to fine-tune things like that
and it just creates this
this pandering citizenry
who think their job
is to supplicate
to the government who's gonna
be the one and you know,
I'm gonna make an argument
about why I've not been naughty
and I'm nice and he's been
the one who's been naughty
and it just tears society
apart in that in that way.
It's terribly unhealthy
and there's no evidence
whatsoever does anything,
but create disasters as far.
You know, I lived in
communist China in 83, 84
when they first opened up
and I saw a lot of this
stuff unfolding there
and it's yeah, it's kind of,
it's their lack of education
makes them not understand
what the necessary consequences
of having government get
in the business and deciding
who's been naughty and nice
and giving special favors to.
It just turns the whole society
into this corrupt throne
sniffing supplicant
to the powers that
be in government.
- What do you
really feel Patrick?
What do you really feel?
- It's throne
sniffing getting by.
- I don't think you
can say thrones,
no please, the whole
mainstream media
is gonna be throne sniffing
for the next four years.
So yeah, but wait,
so bringing this back
to the big tech part.
Because you were
running over stock,
you you're well known in the
crypto world and all that.
When people look at these
guys like Zuckerberg
or like Jack Dorsey at
Twitter or the rest of them,
and they, I think a
lot of people think
that they're sort of these
inherently evil characters.
Well, I'm a little
more sympathetic to
the human condition
of they're managing these
virtually unmanageable things.
I think they do have
a lot of the bad ideas
that you're talking about.
I think they've shown themselves
to you know only censor
one side, the whole thing.
Do you have any sympathy as a
guy that's run big businesses
that with the type of
stuff that they have
to manage these days and the
pressures from government
or do the millions
make up for it
that they're getting paid?
The hundreds the millions?
- The millions make up for it.
No, I don't have any sympathy.
The way to handle it is
just keep everything simple.
Keep the truth the truth
and keep the rules simple.
Simple rules for
a complex world.
If you start getting in
the business of censoring
by content, by viewpoint,
you know then you,
then you in Facebook are
gonna need your department
of who's been naughty and nice.
It's a terrible road to go down.
I actually, I gotta tell you
all I know about
Zuckerberg is this Chinese.
I hate to be a mandarin
snob, but his Chinese stinks.
In about six weeks
of studying Chinese,
this guy's been married to a
Chinese woman for 10 years.
His Chinese sounds to me like,
probably minded after
about six weeks of study
at Dartmouth College.
And that tells me a lot.
This guy studied it for years,
got a Chinese wife.
His Chinese is so grating
it tells me you know,
he just came up
with a good idea.
Well, he must be real smart
in other ways not everyone is,
although it could be he just
stole the ideas, of course.
- I did see the movie,
I did see the movie.
How is your mandarin now?
(speaks in foreign language)
- Do you wanna send
some sort of message
to our new Chinese overlords
that maybe the
YouTube sensors won't,
well I guess they'd
be happy about it.
(speaks in Chinese)
I am a great admirer
of the Chinese.
- We got --
- You can get, yeah
you can turn that
into a native speaker
and they can translate.
So yeah, it's a shame,
I've loved China,
and this is probably a
dangerous thing to admit.
I'm an old China hand.
I grew up loving China.
I saw it as my, if I had a
historical role in the world,
it was gonna be
to somehow build.
I think the best thing
that could happen
for the world is some
sort of merger of the US
and Chinese principles that
actually could create a healthy,
perpetual piece for the world.
We have a lot to learn
from the Chinese,
they do some things very well.
Their family, their traditions,
their focus on education
and building human capital.
All kinds of things I saw
in China and I thought boy,
this is what we need
to see more of here,
but what I love about
our system is freedom,
and there needs to be some sort
of merger of those interests
and if, they may not be
really the ultimate
guys behind this.
They may be involved,
it may be somebody else,
the truth will come out I
think sooner rather than later,
but if they have been
involved in this,
all I can say is it's a
real disappointment to me
because I spent my
whole life thinking
of them as my friends.
I kind of love them almost as
much as I do America, frankly.
So I have to say in in full
transparency when we met
just a couple weeks ago, you
said to me hey Dave you know,
I really like what you're doing
and I think you said
something about Locals.com
and I said oh well,
maybe we should talk.
We literally got on the
phone like a day later.
I had you meet my business
partner about two days later.
You immediately invested,
so you do own a
piece of Locals.com
which is thrilling for us
and I think you're
gonna help us navigate
these really freaking, these
nasty waters basically.
These really rough waters that
we're about to go through.
Is there something,
I'll do it publicly,
is there something we
should be thinking about
as this company's
growing right now
in the midst of all of this
that maybe I'm not
thinking about yet?
- Keep the faith.
I do not think we're
gonna lose this.
I actually think that we're
gonna win, keep the faith.
I would say that they
say in (mumbles) capital,
bet the jockey
and not the horse.
When I met you that's, I
knew I wanted to bet on you
as the jockey.
At least as much about that
as your fundamental
underlying idea,
however what you spoke
to me about with Locals
sounded so precisely
matching my view of the world
and what was needed and a way
to be off the main platforms
in a way they could
not come after
which I think when
we spoke about it,
we thought it might be
some distant abstract.
We didn't realize it
three weeks later.
- Yeah, I didn't realize
three weeks, you know.
But at least a month,
at least a month.
What's next for you?
- Well I'm gonna see how this
plays out over the next week
and then I'm gonna take it easy.
I sort of just had a
tough year and a half
since I left the company
and we're gonna see
how this plays out then
I'm gonna take it easy.
Probably go lay somewhere
warm in the sun is
what I need to do.
I probably should be
doing it right now,
but go lay in the sun in
some tropical location is
what I really love to do.
- That sounds like a plan.
Well, Patrick I'm thrilled
that we finally did this.
I'm thrilled that we're
partnered up on Locals
and we shall see, we
shall see what happens.
I normally don't end
a show like that,
but I feel like that's
the best I got right now.
Like we shall see right?
- May you live, as
the Chinese say,
may you live in
uninteresting times.
- Yeah, unfortunately we
got the interesting times
which I know is a Chinese
curse, that's the problem.
- Right, but I'll be watching
Locals with great interest
and I think half of America is
fed up with this censorship.
They're gonna
gravitate very quickly
to what you have to offer.
- Thanks, well I wish
I could tell people
to follow you on Twitter,
but you are suspended.
Where can I send them at least?
Is there any other
place I can send them?
Deep capture, deepcapture.com.
That's where I've been
writing for about 15 years.
When I have something
to tell the world,
I put it up there.
- Great awesome, well thank
you so much and feel better,
drink some OJ, we'll talk soon.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about tech
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our tech playlist
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist,
they're right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.